- Kids'...
(Kelly chortles)
(beep)
Kids' pictures with Santa.
I actually have a great story.
I need to find this one
Santa and apologize.
(Kelly chuckles)
(buzzer)
(festive music)
All right, everybody,
if you know me at all,
you know I love Christmas.
I really, really do.
It's my favorite holiday.
It's so much fun.
I love the music.
I love the music so much, in fact,
I'm actually releasing
a second Christmas album
that comes out today.
And why are we releasing it
in October before Halloween?
Because why the hell not?
And because you only get so long
to listen to Christmas music.
I'm very excited about the album,
it's called "When
Christmas Comes Around..."
because everybody's in a different place,
and it depends on the year
and chapter of your life.
And there's literally a song for every
kind of emotion you might be having.
There's sad, there's happy,
there's let's go out and
get a Christmas tree,
and then there's sexy.
There's all these different songs.
There's some originals,
and then there's also some classics.
My new single for it,
which is "Christmas Isn't
Canceled (Just You)",
I actually don't believe
in cancel culture.
It was just a funny play off of like
maybe your relationship went sour
or maybe everything isn't going okay.
That doesn't mean everything is bad.
Christmas is coming and it's not canceled,
just maybe a portion of your life.
To celebrate the release of my new album,
its first single, "Christmas
Isn't Canceled (Just You)",
in the holidays,
I'm going to play a
fun holiday game called
Christmas Isn't Canceled...
But What Should Be?
Pumpkin spice lattes?
(ding)
With almond milk, please.
Because I'm lactose intolerant.
I love pumpkin, I love
spice, and I love a latte.
So definitely liking that, yep.
I love all Christmas drinks.
I love having a Christmas drink in June
and feeling like it's Christmas.
It's just as nice.
Okay, elf on a shelf.
Love elf on a shelf.
(ding)
We'll say that,
man, that elf works hard
on all those little scenarios.
That elf is just going fishing sometimes.
He shows up, and he's been at soccer camp.
He's... There's a lot of things.
He's scaling a wall.
Like that elf...
It's a lot of hard work parents, right?
We're thinking those
elves work really hard.
But I will say it's really fun,
and I love when the elf visits,
and it's magical so.
All right, so decorating for Christmas
much earlier than December.
Than December?
(ding)
Of course you're
decorating before December.
Do you know how much money
you spend on those lights
and those decorations?
I think it's fine to start...
I decorate my house big time.
Usually we start November 1st.
Because it's, you get two full months
of all the prettiness.
Because I love Christmas,
and it makes you feel happy, right?
You're coming in your driveway,
it's all lit up.
It's magical.
I'm liking that.
"Die Hard" being considered
a Christmas movie?
Absolutely!
(ding)
They're at a Christmas party.
He rescues them at a Christmas party.
Anything with Alan Rickman,
even Harry Potter, okay?
He's in that too.
But I will say "Die Hard" is
definitely one of my faves.
All of them, all the "Die Hards".
Of course it's a Christmas classic.
Get outta here.
Eggnog?
Yes.
(ding)
Nothing is being canceled today people.
You know why?
I shouldn't drink eggnog
because it can upset my tummy,
but they have almond eggnog now.
They have different kinds of eggnog now.
But you know what's really not canceled?
Spiked eggnog.
I will say,
what is canceled
(buzzer)
is what might happen to
me after drinking eggnog.
(Kelly laughs)
Ugly Christmas sweaters?
What?
(ding)
Ugly Christmas sweaters are always funny.
And it's also a time like
I feel like everybody,
maybe it's just me,
but I have to get dressed up
all the time for work, okay?
So you know what? No.
If my family's coming over,
you have to love me regardless, okay?
So yeah, you're gonna
love me in my sweats.
Why am I dressing up for you?
Like why would I do that?
Black Friday shopping crowds?
(buzzer)
Looking at you, mom.
This is why it's canceled, okay?
(buzzer)
It was a Walmart and it
was in Burleson, Texas.
And my mom was like,
"We gotta get there early
because the deals..."
(Kelly gargles)
And she dragged me there.
I had to fight grown men and women.
I was a freshman in high school
fighting off for this TV.
People get crazy.
I'm like, it's not that great of a deal.
My God, to sacrifice your
character and one's dignity.
Like geez!
But I will say, it's awesome now
because they do a lot of it online.
That's cool
because then you don't
have to leave your couch,
and you can be in your
ugly Christmas sweater
drinking some eggnog.
(Kelly chuckles)
Last-minute Christmas present wrapping?
Not a fan.
(buzzer)
I know that sometimes it happens
maybe with one or two gifts,
that's acceptable.
But canceled in general.
Like I...
The end of the year for me
is my busiest time with all the jobs.
And I generally am done very early.
Early.
I mean, I'm usually a month in advance.
I love wrapping Christmas presents.
It's an art form.
It's not just wrapping paper.
It's selected wrapping
paper for each gift,
and also there's jute rope involved,
and also those little things added to it.
It's a lot, and I love it.
My favorite wrapping though,
and I've changed it up
because I know I have children
that like bright and fun,
like whatever.
But my favorite is just a
good old parchment paper,
wrapped with jute rope,
and a little reindeer
thingy hanging off of it,
maybe some jingle bells.
(bells jingles)
I like a really classic look,
but I do have children,
so I spice it up with some fun stuff too.
Kids'...
(Kelly chortles)
Kids' pictures with Santa.
I actually have a great story for that.
I need to find this one
Santa and apologize.
(Kelly chuckles)
(buzzer)
I think this should be canceled
because it's a, ugh,
it's a big thing.
And then a lot of times you end up crying,
or it's just like,
they change their gifts
when they talk to him.
And you're like, Santa,
maybe he doesn't have time to run around
and get different ones.
I don't know, like Santa's busy.
It was either last year
or the year before,
I took my kids with my
friend Trisha to go see,
and my friend Trisha had to go
because I couldn't drive
because I hurt myself.
It's like we end up in here,
it's chaos getting through.
We're supposed to follow
this story on our thing.
We missed it somehow...
I don't know what hap...
It was just really hard to follow the app
or it wasn't connecting.
Everything and my kids were
like wining at some point.
It just was chaos.
And then by the time we
get there, all of a sudden,
she's like, "Oh, we get out of the car".
And so then, I'm hurt,
with a crutch, right?
Hurt, and I'm like...
There are all these cars behind
us the whole time, right?
The whole time there's
all these cars behind us.
So I'm like, "Oh my god".
I'm panicking, I'm sweating.
I'm gonna be like hopping to Santa.
I walk just on my foot, just whatever,
adrenaline kicks in.
Trisha's like, "Why are you walking?"
The kids, I'm rushing over.
Santa is just like,
first of all, you can't be
with him because of COVID,
so it's like the weirdest
Santa picture ever.
He's like over there,
and we're like here,
and we're pretending he's there.
And the kids don't get it.
They're so young.
And then I'm just like, "Stand there!"
It was chaos.
(guy behind camera laughs)
I yelled at Santa.
I did yell at Santa.
Not hardcore,
but I was definitely...
I reprimanded Santa.
(Kelly chuckles)
Because he was asking a lot,
and my kids were so young,
and I was like, "What
is your damage, Santa?"
Like what...
They're like four and six, dude.
And they don't understand
why you're over there.
It was hard.
And then my foot, and it was a lot.
But to that Santa who
totally thinks I'm crazy,
(Kelly laughs)
I'm sorry.
It wasn't very magical,
but we're probably gonna
do it again this year.
(Kelly laughs loudly)
All right, y'all,
thank you so much for hanging out with me.
You know what's not canceled?
My awesome new album.
It's called "When Christmas Comes Around".
I hope you dig it.
We worked really hard on it.
It's a very different
kind of Christmas album
than you're probably used to,
but it's where I was at in my life.
So I enjoyed making it,
and if you don't like it,
you're getting coal in your stocking.
(Kelly laughs)
(festive music)
Goodbye.